I know wind welcome to this video
back to back against mr. tacos let's see
okay six we play pretty non theoretical
in the in the other games well okay
we're interesting to see how is going to
get some player with f6 maybe
just as such an easy game and you can
really play every single move in a split
second and still have a good position
the second part of the sentence is not
true so let's see um okay if I take
twice he has to take okay I'm going to
do the same so I think it's better
so you want to get a little bit of play
hands it's understandable but 86 and
okay Pont I don't want to cheat with the
deep harm
so it's got a bad night here a bad night
here a bad Roker bad bishop okay
hey he was one of those cons I mean it's
really little
dower damn he has to give up one of
those crowns doesn't seem like he agrees
with this assumption okay should damn
it's also good on f6
whenever he moves to c8 night he will
lose some e6000 sex but yeah so just
take its it's actually not totally clear
how I should do this because it is so
utterly bad and yeah I probably just
really take it six because I actually I
keep the pressure on it doesn't really
I'm not giving up any any strategic
advantage that's what I'm trying to say
by playing this way 96
and this is actually a good defense
tink yeah but okay I can take and pin
him threatening is six
you know I probably had a better way to
play this I mean it's it's a winning
position the winning ending but it was
so bad that I think there probably was
something even better
but how to how to win probably point to
a 4/9 or I can just cannot see it now
what is seem trying to trap the bishop
in any case
mmm
b6
yeah yeah I know this is kind of a pet
peeve of mine young people playing like
here he had he had three point three on
the clock
and the position is total total crap
just no play of all this stuff and I
don't get why you not even spend some
seconds to play somewhat normal opening
moves I mean this already looks weird
but okay let's not so one thing that is
interesting is taking with this pawn but
it's a fairly normal way to do it just
to have pressure on the sefa
he has a five plate that makes this more
interesting as any c5 is weakening b5
and generally don't quite know what
blacks plan is he just sitting around
basically and this is weakening even
more and now yeah 95 doesn't even seem
to be best yeah but I mean it it is not
bad it will probably wind c-4 in the
long run but after after this I think
it's just over this is strategically so
bad the night is on b5 26 and it just
run you simply cannot move here c6 is a
big hole and this is just not going to
work multiple good and I mean maybe I
have played it a bit too simplistic Leah
simplistically is that it would no
simplistic no yeah I mean it wins but it
looked more like you can always can mate
but yeah just picking up all the pawns
this is certainly enough yeah I I really
don't get why I mean I understand you to
play the opening quickly this is fine
but if you play something that is kind
of garbage anyway at least like a little
bit yeah a couple of seconds to to not
get into a lost position after twelve or
thirteen moves or something and I don't
know and I don't really get people must
get punished if you play like that all
the time but maybe they aren't I don't
know okay
thanks for watching